التجاري بين ما لدينا يتم في الروبل
واليوان بنسبه اثنين الثلثين
محاسبات التي تجري بين روسيا ودول اسيا
وامريكا التينيه وافريقيا فهذا سوف يتطور
ضمن العملات الوطنيه
والدول الاخرى ايضا يمكن ان يتم عبر
اليوان وهناك ايضا
تعاون في بناء الطيران المدني والسفن
وبناء وصناعه السيارات ومستعدون لدعم
الاعمال الصينيه في تعويض الشركات التي
انسحبت منها السوق الروسيه
وهناك ايضا اهميه بالمنتجات الزراعيه حيث
ازدادت بنسبه 41.4%
[موسيقى]
وصلت الى سبعه مليارات دولار وهذا النمو
كان
بنسبه متساويه من قبل الطرفين والوزارات
المختصه تقوم
بالتاكيد على نوعيه المنتجات التي يتم
ايصالها وتوريدها وهذا كله يسمح للنمو
الاضافي
للمنتجات الزراعيه الى اسواق الصينيه
ويمكن ان هذا ان يضمن للامن الغذائي
لبلدينا
اساس استقرار هذا النمو والتطور هو
السياده والاستقلال التقني ونحن نذهب نحو
مسار اكمال
الشراكه في
صناعات المحدده وخاصه فان روسيا والصين
يمكن ان يكون
دولتان رائدتان في مجال الصناعات التقنيه
والذكاء الاصطناعي ونتيجه لتعاوننا في
المجال
التجاري والاستثمار فهذا يعزز بنا التطور
العلاقات بين الاقاليم ولذلك كان
الصين شريكا اساسيا في استثمارات في الشرق
الاقصى
وايضا منها المرفا في فلادي ايفوس حيث
يقوم
باستثمار في 52
مشروعا بقيمه 10.8 مليار دولار وهناك
شراكه مزدوجه بما في ذلك
135 في
روسيا الاتحاديه الاقاليم
العمل بين الاقليم في روسيا
الصين هناك اتفاقيات
ويوجد ايضا بنيه تحتيه للنقل يتم تطويرها
ونحن نعمل على تطوير الخطوط البريه ولذلك
لدينا اولويه في
صياغه او بناء الممرات البريه وسكك الحديد
والتي تمر عبر اراضينا والتي وفقا للطلب
والتهديدات التي تؤثر على النقل
وايضا لقد تم فتح الجسر
وفي نوفمبر تم ايضا فتح جسر لسكك الحديد
وهذا سمح بتقليص التكاليف لنقل
البضائع بين روسيا والصين ووسعه جغرافيه
النقل الى
بلداني الاسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وايضا للعمل على الاستفاده من الممر البحر
الشمالي مع التعاون مع الصين فنحن مستعدون
لتشكيل هيئه مخصصه لتطوير هذا الشمالي
وبعد انتهاء الجائحه فان هناك نمو للتبادل
السياحي والتبادل الثقافي للشباب في عام
2022 لقد درس في الجامعات الصينيه
6500 الطالب والذي من بينهم الف
كانوا موجودون في الصين ومنهم والباقي
كانوا عند يدرسون عن بعد وهناك يدرس في
روسيا 37
او سبعه الاف طالب من الصين في روسيا
تبادل الثقافي في السنه التبادل
فهناك اكثر من 100 فعاليه ومنها ايضا
الفعاليات الرياضيه التي اصبحت مهمه حيث
ان الحركه الاولمبيه بدات تبدو مسيسه
ويستخدمون الرياضه كاداه للضغط في الغرب
ولذلك فان دعم تشكيل
روابطات رياضيه ضمن اطار منظمه شنغهاي
للتعاون
وهناك
في كافه الاتجاهات الذي سوف يتعزز في
المستقبل
لدعم
شعب البلدين والان انقل الكلمه الى ضيفنا
وصديقي الرئيس الصيني فليتفضل
[موسيقى]
ان نتطور الشراكه في التجاره والثقافه
والسعيد الدولي
في الامس خلل لقائنا غير رسمي وخلل
المباحثات مع رئيس الوزراء
وخلل المباحثات في الصيغه الضيقه
قمنا بتبادله وجهات النظر حول
مسارات التعاون
وحول مسارات التعسيه تعاوننا
لقد توصلنا الى نتائج ملموسه في
شركتنا ونقوم
بتطوير التعاون
ولقد ذكر الرئيس بوتين
يوم الجاري
في الصين مكرس العام الجاري في الصين مكرس
للجنه العشرين والدوره العشرين للجنه حزب
الشيوعيه الصيني في هذا الاطار
نقوم
بدفع قدما التحديث
للاليات السنيه ونعمل
تطوير اهدافنا
للشراكه الشامله حتى عام 2003 واقترح
عليكم
التعزيز قدراتنا للتعاون لكي نستفيد من
الشراكه وهذا التعاون والسيد الرئيس
استعداد لتحديد خطه
تطوير للعلاقات
الثنائيه وشراكه العمليه اليس على ازدهار
واحيا روسيا والصين وبهذا وصلنا لخدام